[Music]
cameron is here with a surprising move
from making Markos got a few fans a
little angry but not all because she and
Harry were just swarmed by fans she
better get used to that that is for sure
it happened during their first
engagement of the new year but if you
want to follow Megan on social media you
can forget about that because she just
shut it all down
Megan used to share candid selfies like
these but today her Instagram and
Twitter accounts were deleted from now
on we will only see the photos to Palace
post on their official social media
today Megan wave to a cheering crowd as
she and Harry paid a visit to a London
radio station wrapped up in a camel coat
and scarf over black pants and heels the
future royal showed off a new hairdo the
casual trendy messy bun style with loose
bits of hair on the sides is a break
from the more traditional royal sleek
look her brand o coat by Canadian brand
Smythe is already sold out inside the
station Megan went for basic black and a
belted sweater over her pants the pair
went to represent radio to see how young
people are getting trained in
broadcasting Harry even learned this
fist bump handshake in other royal news
today is Kate Middleton's 36th birthday
the pregnant Duchess is actually five
months younger than her future
sister-in-law Megan and Kate's daughter
Princess Charlotte is actually a mini-me
of the Queen in her new nursery school
photos the two and a half year old looks
a lot like her great-grandmother when
she was a tot Evon down to the side
parted hair little Charlotte also shares
her resemblance to her father's mother
here was a young lady Diana Spencer when
she was around Charlotte's age what a
cutie at the door whoever she looks like
we hope we see Charlotte play a part in
Harry and Megan's I Do's which is just
130 days away a lot of people excited
about that
[Music]
you